sounds good resume do you ever just look
back in your life and yeah well this has
been a great video I mean do you ever
just think like whoa I want to play some
weird games all right well that's cool I
guess
that's what we're doing today first one
I download it download it's [ __ ]
downloaded free holster for iPhone and
iPad okay all right
here it is here's the head oh you're
looking at me no it's not gonna you
brush he's crying
what a puss sorry my feelings were
trying to trying to come out there for a
second I don't know what happened all
right there's an arrow here where you
win
oh well go back damn it oh it grew back
that's good ah bye bye noses don't need
you anyway
freakin Michael Jackson simulator I
don't know that was oh now you're just
being ridiculous
does it spin yeah go to space am I am I
supposed to be I'm drunk so while I play
this I I don't understand why Oh God
don't don't go back in please thank you
that was not very nice all right I'll
click on all these oh you're now an elf
nope I want you to be an elephant is
that said too much guys can't write well
eating that [ __ ] eating it you dirty
[ __ ] you would eat it you would like it
no he's giving birth to Satan that's
wonderful
it's quite brighter this time of year
we're quite lucky breasts what's going
on here what is this skin is so [ __ ]
weird
oh is that all right take those Tiffany
oh yeah ah show me the movie
oh there you go I found you you have a
[ __ ] you [ __ ] back out God there's some
Iran erotica with this that I actually
quite like all right all right let it go
let it go
shut up seriously dude I have let it go
syndrome all right it's a serious
problem doctors are still trying to
figure out how to solve it playing with
it that's adorable play with this man if
you want to be a bother I feel like
never make up head more balls now what
okay well what is that
now come on what do you do hey let's
stop this game man what happened you
grow hair in his ear
okay this is how it works of course well
that looks nice I'll keep it that way
thank you stop growing ham Wow we can
jump - uh all right damn it
so much hair how should we style it
mm-hmm
you're gonna be a star you're gonna be
fabulous you get my supposed to make
them run somewhere like I don't yeah you
got that's the words jump I've seen in
my life get your [ __ ] together Bob jump
accordingly seriously I don't know I
solutely know I have absolutely no idea
what I'm doing but I kind of love it
especially the beard I love the beard
hit my cool yet well damn it my hair is
better than yours how about that oh my
god there's a there's a thing here play
now wait you're supposed to play it oh
there's a there's a there's another ten
into ten of course and there's a ball
eat it you bet I'm gonna drown opposite
Rock what these fell down
you don't want DOS I'm feeding them to
the fishes of course of course
Oh another ball yay I like your back
hair Y that's how you like it bad
hey hey hey hello Oh God Oh God kill it
what was that what what side oh my god
oh my god what is that just kill it oh
[ __ ]
don't hurt me oh god [ __ ] let's scare
this game I don't play my life why oh
thank god what is that this is worse
than any drugs a worm
stop no worm you're not gonna get my
mouse and they're all yarn that's
terrible
oh my gosh I can't I literally can oh
and and and we float away in the Bell
mache and it recites are you weirded out
yet cuz there's more all right
next game is made by the same man a guy
and it's runs another flash play nice
it's cause we don't still Oh God
Oh in my trip of phobia mmm-hmm
god no we're not touching that one what
the hell is this how do we get the
lights on
not good ah there it is no that found it
there's a crack in the one there's a
snake in my bats a bouncing boat she
likes to bounce don't you like the
balance don't you how we can take the
cube where are you going bread balance
is so awesome all right hold this we
just hi there little five no where did
you go
whoops whoops whoops no no no is that my
letters and I decide how they are pitch
that's right stop it Cara do something I
need I need the square from the eye
that's what I need there we go all right
thank you
I'd be on my way now what no we're fine
what happened oh don't um I come in
peace please no no okay fine heat it see
if I hear of course of course
whoa oh you want it I know you want it
little bit you damn it she won ah oh how
nice
thank you buddy see you then eh mmm
lovely now of course that fruits that
isn't fruits oh of course of course I
can do this all day all day son okay
there's something satisfying about doing
this
okay hey someone want to pet a Papa
there we go you go in there brush of
course it's a spaceship right got it
charge it up like I'm gasoline engine
wha-what yes that's it Rick now what now
god I don't even want it oh god what's
gonna happen of course of course
taste it did I do it I think I unlocked
the matrix yes I did
I'm scared of going in the next room
like you never know what's gonna happen
you never know if you're your childhood
dreams will disappear or if you will
summon Satan I don't know oh god I think
I did damn it this is not what I ordered
all right this is like go into a
restaurant and you get an ass on a plate
am I supposed to line a phase is that
it's not the point
no that's a 60s face mate shut up Dutch
side by side yes oh my god it came to me
like that there's something so
satisfying when you finally find the
Bates just like real and zinger Bing oh
god those are legs huh all right let's
uh straight take a take a little star
how I wonder where you are
I might make him something out of this
it's not a purposing knife what inside a
ball I'll place you there this is like
adventure games in a nut shell like you
just [ __ ] click [ __ ] and all the
sudden something works we're filling it
out somebody's gonna come out a cloud
how nice that rains ice cubes
all right
Oh what what I sold it and I even
realize how long has that been there ha
what all right yeah what fine I'll take
it I'll take it I were in the color Sam
of course of course yeah of course
nothing surprises me anymore life will
just be empty after all this that what
who drop date you drop you know [ __ ]
it's not as tricky as hell there we go
I might have done it now what give it to
me yes victory little body Bob I love
you
one day we'll get babies and we'll call
them Bob Lisa and Bob Bert those are
very ugly names but so are you Bob
hey Bob don't be shy you little [ __ ]
now you I want you to go to space and
never forget about my name and I love
that we share together in these moments
oh oh oh oh oh oh it's happening it's
happening all right all right
doomsday is coming I knew it I predicted
it mm 2k14
all right well [ __ ] it don't do it then
oh I don't care
Oh the stars the constellations how can
I not real gonna be so blind
no go Bob be one with the gods you have
a godly ass at least that's for sure I
dream about getting a fish in an ocean
full of pee this is where DreamWorks got
their logo from what are you doing to
that poor old face and there's Bob of
course floating to the sky we will now
sing our national his national anthem
dude you every night in my dream I see
you I pee on you